By now, we’re all familiar with the concept
of parallel universes, right?
In fact, those of you who are familiar with
the SCP Foundation or are maybe even long-time
fans of the videos on this channel will know
that there are multiple universes that exist
besides our own.
There might even be those of you out there
with such refined knowledge that you could
even name some of the various different universes
and dimensions that the Foundation has come
into contact with over their years studying
anomalies.
Today, we’re taking a look at one such anomaly,
an interdimensional wormhole connecting to
an alternate universe known as SCP-1322, or
by the somewhat questionable nickname, the
Glory Hole.
And no, not the one in the airport bathroom
in Minneapolis.
Let’s take you back to 1952, imagine you’re
a researcher working for the SCP Foundation.
It’s August, and a new anomaly has been
discovered; it’s a stabilized breach in
the very fabric of space-time, an aperture
into a completely different universe than
the one you know.
A month later, the Foundation has managed
to secure control around this new SCP-1322,
establishing Site 122 around the breach, given
that this wormhole has a fixed position and
doesn’t seem to move at all.
In only another month’s time, you watch
as a metal cylinder one day appears as if
from nowhere, pushed through SCP-1322 by someone,
or something on the other side.
Naturally, there’s a buzz among you and
your fellow researchers.
What is this thing?
Is it dangerous?
How did it get here?
The cylinder is sent off and quarantined,
then sterilized so that it can be safely examined.
Upon closer examination, it turns out it’s
a hollow container with a screw cap, almost
like a thermos flask.
And inside?
A number of triangular sheets of what appears
to be paper, with strange glyphs written on
them.
It’s a message in a bottle, from a completely
separate reality.
The months go by and experiments involving
SCP-1322 are in full swing.
But, while you were probably expecting there
to be full-scale explorations through the
wormhole, your job as a researcher seems to
just be throwing objects attached to rope
through SCP-1322.
In fact, the most exciting that those early
experiments got was taking atmosphere samples
from the other side of the wormhole.
Even then, you only learn that there’s very
little different about the other dimension’s
atmosphere when compared to normal Earth levels,
apart from a slightly higher concentration
of argon in the air.
Unfortunately, despite even more of the metal
cylinders appearing through the wormhole,
very little remarkable happens with SCP-1322
over the course of the rest of the year.
It’s not until July 1953, almost an entire
year after the anomaly was first discovered,
that the Foundation’s linguistic experts
finally make a breakthrough studying the strange
glyphic messages.
The first exciting thing to happen with this
wormhole, and it was some other department
that uncovered it.
What a bummer.
Thanks to the help of their in-house linguistic
and mathematical experts, the Foundation determined
that the glyphs were some form of cordial,
friendly greeting, but using geometric components
within written language.
Imagine if math and written words had a baby.
No, not your algebra homework.
Anyway, using the same system of communication,
the Foundation’s linguists sent a reply
back through SCP-1322 in one of the metal
containers.
And then… nothing, no more messages.
For three whole months, the wormhole fell
silent.
The only thing breaking that lapse in contact
was a light that appeared to activate on the
far side of SCP-1322.
Observations revealed that somebody seemed
to have constructed a new containment chamber
but on the other side of the wormhole.
In October of 1953, the SCP Foundation finally
began extensive communication with those on
the opposite side of SCP-1322.
Through the frequent exchange of written messages,
research teams learned that the glyphs were
a common system of non-verbal communication
in this alternate universe, a place that soon
became known as SCP-1322-A. Members of this
dimension’s civilization soon started to
pick up and incorporate English into their
correspondence with the Foundation, until
they were eventually able to set up a telegraph,
that used a specially shielded cable running
through the wormhole, allowing those in dimension
SCP-1322-A to talk to the SCP Foundation on
the other side.
The civilization that existed beyond SCP-1322
was apparently a society of human beings,
almost identical to the people of our own
universe.
The people that the Foundation was in direct
contact with on the other side were members
of a scientific organization that had been
tasked with handling the area that surrounded
SCP-1322 in their universe.
Not too dissimilar from the Foundation themselves,
by the sound of it.
However, the biggest dissimilarity between
the inhabitants of each parallel world was
their different levels of scientific understanding.
What do we mean by that?
Well, like many in our universe, the Foundation
scientists on this side had a pretty well-rounded
and balanced understanding of biology, physics,
and chemistry.
But those in SCP-1322-A were part of a civilization
that had a far more in-depth understanding
of only physics, with far less knowledge of
biological science than we might have.
The SCP-1322-A inhabitants had made many great
strides in the fields of mathematics and high
energy physics, and this had enabled their
civilization to possess a level of technological
and engineering sophistication that people
in our world could only dream of.
And yet, they were hindered by how little
they understood basic biology, such as how
aspects of nature and human bodies work.
The people of SCP-1322-A expressed a strong
interest in exchanging samples of music, art,
literature, and mathematics with the Foundation,
but seemed to have no interest in religion
or medicine.
And so the exchange went on, with the denizens
of SCP-1322 sharing detailed records of their
advanced astronomical observations, encouraging
the Foundation to emulate their deep space
findings.
That must’ve been nice, essentially getting
a cheat sheet or a “things to look out for
in space” guide from an advanced alternate
universe.
Or, it would have been nice if the data the
Foundation received from the other side actually
lined up with our own observable universe.
The Foundation flagged this issue up with
the SCP-1322-A, and they responded by saying
that personnel should have more candor in
the future if their civilizations were to
continue sharing scientific findings.
Needless to say, tensions were beginning to
emerge between these two different universes.
Following lapses in communication from their
side, the inhabitants of SCP-1322-A reported
that there had been some form of viral outbreak
in their universe.
This had seemingly spread from members of
their own organization, infecting the area
surrounding SCP-1322 and ultimately leading
to the local government imposing quarantine
measures.
The Foundation offered to assist, asking for
a sample of this virus, which they then received.
Analyzing it, they learned it was nothing
more than a harmless variant of the common
flu, and worked with SCP-1322-A to create
an antidote.
Now, the flu might not sound all that bad,
but remember, beyond that little wormhole
was a universe that hadn’t made anywhere
near the advances in biology that we have.
SCP-1322-A didn’t have vaccines or treatments
to deal with an infection like this, and so
when this flu virus found itself in their
world - perhaps through a message that was
passed to them through SCP-1322 - it was able
to cause widespread fatalities.
Eight million, almost ten whole percent of
SCP-1322-A’s population was killed by the
outbreak.
Gradually, however, the Foundation was able
to help them get it under control, but that
wasn’t the end of their troubles.
After successfully inoculating their world
against the virus in October 1973, SCP-1322-A
reported that there had been an unexpected
decrease in pregnancies.
The following year, the birth rate had dropped
significantly, which was then found to be
an unexpected side effect of the vaccine the
Foundation had given to SCP-1322-A to stop
the flu.
According to them, this had had the knock-on
effect of creating widespread social disorder.
In January of 1975, when the Foundation once
again offered the people of this alternate
universe assistance, they were met with the
response “NO THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE DONE ENOUGH.”
Later that same year, some new management
assumed control of the organization on the
other side of the wormhole.
They maintained an open line of communication
with the Foundation, but in a far more aggressive
manner, almost as if they were accusing them
of the troubles now faced by their world.
There was massive upheaval across their globe,
with less than a thousand live births between
July and September of 1975.
During that time, the organization refused
to exchange any further scientific or cultural
information with the Foundation, and eventually,
in October 1975, it severed ties completely.
They sent a final communication condemning
the SCP Foundation, stating “YOU KILLED
US.
YOU DID THIS TO US.
IN YOUR CARELESSNESS AND YOUR ARROGANCE YOU
HAVE DESTROYED OUR POSTERITY.
BUT WE SHALL AVENGE.
WE OF THE LAST GENERATION PLEDGE AND VOW THIS.
WE WILL FIND A WAY.”
After that, things were quiet.
A few stray pathogens made their way through
SCP-1322 but were swiftly destroyed before
they could spread.
Then, in January 1977, a high-energy particle
beam was fired through the wormhole at Foundation
staff.
It caused minor damage to the containment
chamber, but this was repaired.
The same thing would happen again in 1984,
a high energy blast this time followed by
more of the pathogens being sent through the
wormhole.
And so it went on, every few months the people
of SCP-1322-A would try to attack the Foundation
like this, and each time the attempt was futile.
Any damage the beam caused was repaired, and
any pathogens were quickly isolated and destroyed.
In 1991, the Foundation tried filling the
containment chamber housing SCP-1322 with
quick setting ceramic, perhaps to bury the
wormhole for good.
But a month later, their former allies on
the other side released a solvent that ate
through the ceramic.
They then tried changing up their tactics,
firing the particle beam still but now also
beginning to send nanobots, microscopic robots,
through SCP-1322.
But once again, the Foundation was able to
negate any damage that these devices could
do.
These two neighboring universes, home to organizations
that had once tried to share knowledge, were
now engaged in an endless stalemate, a war
with no winner.
A device fell through the wormhole in March
1995, which, upon activation, started to heat
up the atmosphere inside the SCP-1322 containment
chamber.
The air quickly became superheated plasma,
causing considerable damage until it was then
vented from the chamber.
The Foundation had taken their biggest hit
from SCP-1322-A in over a decade and were
forced to seal the wormhole in altered atmospheric
conditions, keeping it essentially within
a vacuum, where nothing, not even air, could
exist.
Three years later, the people of SCP-1322-A
sent another delightful gift to their adversaries:
a miniature nuclear weapon.
This almost decimated Site 122, but the damage
was once again repaired and the threat contained.
Next, in 2006, the residents of the other
universe tried pumping corrosive acid through
the wormhole, once again causing considerable
damage to the containment chamber on the Foundation’s
side.
The following year, the Site 122 Administrator
instructed Foundation personnel to send a
probe through SCP-1322, perhaps to get a better
idea as to what sort of state the neighboring
universe was in after all this time.
A series of eight-kilo iron rods were fired
through the wormhole, however, destroying
the probe before it could reach SCP-1322-A.
They tried again in 2008, this time with a
unique gas that rapidly changed into a solid-state
of matter after it passed through SCP-1322.
This filled the containment chamber, putting
pressure on the structure and threatening
to tear it apart from the inside.
Then, the substance condensed after damaging
the SCP-1322 containment chamber, and more
pathogens and nanobots were introduced.
The goal was to probably spread them further,
out of the chamber to the outside world, but
the Foundation was able to prevent this.
Finally, SCP-1322-A’s last attack involved
a barrage of micro-nuclear warheads, multiple
high-energy particle beams, and an onslaught
of pathogens and nanobots.
But, of course, the Foundation had no trouble
containing this attack and repairing the damage
it caused.
The story of SCP-1322 is an example of that
old saying: “The road to Hell is paved with
good intentions.”
You can start out with a noble goal, say sharing
your scientific knowledge with another universe,
even helping them cure the flu, but sometimes,
something unforeseen can go wrong and turn
former friends into bitter, unforgiving enemies.
These two warring universes are condemned
to continue this sad and deadly dance until
all the lights go out in one or both of them
forever.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Spiral Path”
and “SCP-173 Origin Story - How 173 Got
to Site-19” for more sad tales of inevitable
anomalous tragedy!